it's time for screen junkies movie
fights movie fights live all up in your
face what's going on everybody
welcome to movie fights and I would be
remiss if I did not give a shout out to
hash tag owl Nation who we have a great
one today and we got some fighters who
are ready to throw down
so let us meet the combatants first up
oh she's a great friend of the show you
can see our on FX movie download Sasha
pearl raver I'm loving this rainy scruff
situation this is this is good thing you
know a lot a rainy day calls for some
scruff isn't that what they always say
I'm very excited about these fights man
so am i and I like your sweatshirt no
comment this is a night Anya right here
this is on I think yeah a little bit of
free swag a little bit nice can be that
can be back
this gentleman we I think he made his
first appearance in the debut deathmatch
is that correct yes and but he's been
here since proving that he's come to
play mr. Cameron right hello yeah
Cameron good to have you and uh man
everyone loves burgers fries in a drink
that's an all-american shirt you got
there's a Ross I don't know about
original John Ross good work and this
guy is the head writer of honest
trailers and just nominated Emmy
nominated on Australia's time I mean
losing it's an honor just to be
nominated Spencer Gilbert Thank You Hal
and it is my eternal regret that we
don't have sneaker cam all day every day
with you you are rocking some fresh
black and white aj1
your leg
my entire leg off what's going on on
that shirt what's up is that uh what we
do in the shadows man yes means or the
Beast is nice oh yeah hell yeah tige ytt
um that's an awesome shirt I just I just
got this new beetlejuice yes I'm sure
that I'm pretty psyched about there it
is I think the microphone is blocking it
anyway enough with t-shirt talk let's
talk to our man dan Merle who's always
keeping it box office and factual I'm
wearing screams drinkies t-shirt and a
jacket because it's effing cold in this
building today air conditioning
I always that I remember you when you
got that hat because that's a classic
film image you want to tell them yeah
well this is from the Florida State the
the Student Life Center in Florida State
the game with his hat it's a boy trip to
the moon classic one of the early movies
and I like to do it to represent
everyone at the Student Life Center at
Florida State University yeah it's a
piece of you and yeah that's a that's a
really cool image that they chose for
their hat I thank you sir and the voice
of the people is going to be speaking
for the internet polls Daniel Radford
yes so I am the voice the people there
are many polls that you can find on the
movie fights life hashtag I please
implore you guys all to go and interact
there cuz I do go back and try to read
some of the best answers some of the
dankest memes you know what's done yeah
that's from it anyhow
but the only poll that counts that is
going to be the poll that is on YouTube
and if you're not sure how to use that
click in the description below or ask in
the chat I'm sure someone as a
copy/paste answer ready for you
excellent with that yeah yeah that's
your little cherry on the sundae right
there Thank You Danielle Radford oh yeah
caffeine tell me about it uh just one
little note this is our last live movie
fight of the year but we're gonna have
movie fights locked and loaded every
Thursday
same bat-time same bat-channel so you
gotta get your movie fights this ain't
gonna be live but if you tweeted us
while you
watching it will tweet back at you and
it'll be a whole tweet storm how about
that uh no promises no promises yeah
tweeted Spencer dynomite radio silence
so again here's how it works first
player to four points wins three regular
round questions after the first three
rounds top two players go to the speed
round where it's anybody's ballgame you
can be down three oh and make a furious
comeback
JT drop that sick-ass package
[Music]
[Applause]
Thank You Thor okay this question it's a
real change or ooh it's a real ring a
ding ding a real humdinger of a question
the format's are little bit different so
we're gonna ask the question and then
I'll break down you know what I'll ask
the question everybody just give me your
answers and then we'll let it and what
let people know how the scoring will
work ok so don't elaborate on your
answers just give your answer then we'll
throw it we'll throw it all against the
wall see what sticks so question should
Avengers 4 even have a trailer I was
waiting for this trailer to drop
everybody's got that just like going
back refreshing shouldn't even have a
trailer start with Sasha pearl raver
I can't wait for my ass no Sasha's a no
Cameron no no Cameron's also a no
Spencer give me a pound bro yes ok so we
have to nose and we have one yes this is
like for a wrestling fans I'm talking to
Billy biz I'm talking to Danielle
Radford it's like a handicap match ok
two-on-one so we have the two nose man
coming out talking like the big show all
right so all righty all these faces
he'll show so guys please if you will um
they the tuna the to nose JT just bumped
his head on like
you bumped it with sick ass back in the
shop here's how this works the to nose
will be going up against the one yes if
the two nose win if they take the point
at the end of the round they will each
get one point if Spencer managed to
defeat manages to defeat the both of
them he will be awarded two points
that's how we decided this is gonna work
that's it you don't like it at Billy biz
now it should be noted how yes good if
Spencer were to win this is a best of
four good first a four game shrew so is
Spencer were to win two points and then
win every other round we wouldn't even
need a speedrun i just need this to not
go to the voice of the people because I
know that people read our screaming so
it's all laid out
let's Sasha and Cameron go ahead and
elaborate on your no answer please do
okay well I will just say this there's a
lot to say number one people have
already started tweeting out like hash
tag Marvel versus the fans can I just
say this is what Marvel owes you guys
exactly diddly squat they have already
given you great comics fantastic TV
shows are IP movies that you love and
can watch over and over again the only
thing that you need from them is another
great movie I get that the trailer gets
the excitement going
I love trailers however I feel like we
need to be in the Christopher Nolan's
goal here Christopher Nolan tries to
keep as much back from the audience as
possible so you can go in and have a
really fresh experience never made a
trailer that's true things like he kept
so much close to the vest we were going
through a number of his films but I'm
telling you we've come to a point where
it's all about reactions and the teaser
and this isn't even the trailer that
we're waiting for by the way this is the
teaser trailer we are waiting for we
still have a hundred and forty six days
I don't need 146 days of hype let's get
a taste of Cameron's angle on it the
point of a trailer is
advertisement at this point we all know
Avengers 4 is coming out yep when it's
coming out and the fact of the matter is
Avengers 3 is the highest-grossing movie
of the year I believe and I don't know
anybody who has seen it who if they
didn't like it and don't want to see
adventures for is gonna be won over by a
trailer yeah there's that person doesn't
exist they're not out here the people
who are dying for this trailer are
people who are paying attention to those
algorithms I need to get the that quick
quick trailer reaction cash everyone
else you're gonna see the movie you know
you're gonna go see the movie you don't
need a trailer to go see it at this
point we're already excited about the
new Tom Hollands spider-man because
we've seen images of the suit you can
con image in a magazine Spencer hurt you
guys what why are you taking this this
vile subset of the worst of the worst of
the internet and expanding that to
include everybody who's interested in
seeing maybe an Avengers movie this is
the entire globe you're talking about
and you're focusing on like one hashtag
one tenth of one point one percent of
people who are being dicks about it
people are dicks about everything
there's many things I want taken away
from people like you said you enjoy
trailers people aren't asking for it
well how am I in the position of arguing
for like not being a misanthrope and
like giving people what they want
they're being like grubby little kids
who want their Christmas gifts before
it's you who made you the arbiters of
whether people get to do what they want
or not why by the way my face the option
last I checked was still on the table
for you to do not watch the trailer they
can make a whole spoiler filled trailer
and you could say you know what I'm
gonna go in and spoiled I'm sorry that
you've chose a profession where you work
on the internet and you have to like
react to things but nobody made you do
that you could have stayed in school
hold on
out of my job I have to stay off of
Twitter I have to stay off Instagram I
have to stay off every website I did not
talk to my mom I did not talk to my dad
and we should all suffer for that
I'm so sorry the world should suffer New
York Times is running stories about when
the trailer is going to drop Forbes the
Wall Street Journal because this is a
movie that is critic proof and you're
talking about spoilers everything that
will be in the trailer is going to be
dissected people will look for spoilers
and anything there can literally be like
a glimmer of a half of an inch of
something something to like that was in
combat 127 and now I know that that
means of ember The Avengers trailer last
year people were like oh I think this
little blurry thing right there that's
captain Marvel's insignia that and by
the way they were wrong so it wasn't a
spoiler here's where you guys blew it
you said via should it even have a
trailer we didn't say what kind of
trailer it would have if this is a
monologue from Captain America and it's
just over the text of the new title and
he yells Avengers Assemble at the end of
it that's gonna get everyone off and no
one's gonna be pissed about you can do a
you can have two minutes of the Russo
brothers picking their nose and farting
and everyone like Hammond said is still
gonna show up for this movie sounds
right rally bro he's crazy
his trailer proof we don't need it
because there's several types of ways
they can change the trailer even these
that we can go we do there's so much
what's ago I got something you can do a
custom thing like they did with ice off
one of my favorite trailers where John
Travolta's slowly turns into Nick Cage
and no one on the internet is screaming
for the face of you I'm saying you could
do a custom thing you could do just a
more tonal thing you could you could
pull out one sequence like they did with
guardians of the galaxy or Zootopia or
something like that where you're just
taking one fun sequence from film and
teasing people with it you can do
something that seems like a spoiler like
they did with Iron Man 3 in the Mandarin
but when people see the movie it turns
out it wasn't a spoiler so we don't know
what we're looking at when we analyze
this stuff it's just a fun diversion
like
anything we do in this life I'm getting
hung up on the spoiler part that's not
why I'm saying there shouldn't be a
trailer I'm not saying there shouldn't
be a trailer cuz possible spoilers
people people going crazy all the time
where it's like I wish I was in the
trailer turns out the first two minutes
of the movie no I'm not talking about
spoilers I'm talking about
it ain't needed if Marvel has to
question the trailer the answers doesn't
need a trailer that's a very strong word
we don't need anything but food and
shelter should we have this thing here's
what we if when we have it what do you
do with it once you've enjoyed it so I
can speak on behalf of all casual Marvel
fans because I have the memory of a
goldfish and I don't analyze these
things frame by frame I just watch it I
go oh man that looked awesome I can't
wait to see the movie that's 99% of the
audience of the trailers here's the
thing we have so much time and my
problem is is I feel like we get hyped
and hyped and hyped in height and then
we see the movie and the movie
experience is a two maybe two and a half
hour thing and then it's gone and we've
had a year half a year however much I'm
building up to it and then the actual
experience becomes ephemeral but I don't
think that Marvel's fallen victim to
that I think their trailer said if
anything been underwhelming compared to
the movies themselves you always walk
out like wow that was amazing in the
trailers they're fine they're good
trailers how much hype do we have for
like ant-man and the wasp and then
actually how much of people talked about
that movie after the fact
we know there's hype for that or this is
the least hyped Marvel movie it was just
coming off of our most recent with
Captain Marvel I am very excited for
that movie I cannot wait to see it I did
not watch the trailer because I want to
have a fresh experience and my problem
is is I feel like we have such an
expectation whether you want to or not
whether you do something different with
it or not you will always have an
expectation set and I think it is high
time because we aren't an industry where
we see so much before we see set videos
we have with set visit interviews we
have a million things of publicity
leading up to something I would like to
have a fresh experience you guys are
both coming at this from the perspective
of like insider hardcore nerds who watch
who watch watches
every one my mom watches Avengers movies
my wife watches Avengers movies people
who don't give a [ __ ] about anything
else watch Avengers movies there was not
true they don't know this is coming out
I'm sorry to do this hello what's the
release date of Avengers 4 we have a
television commercial why can't we have
that's a trailer I'm sorry let's roll
this into your final thoughts my final
thought is a trailer and a commercial
are not the same thing a trailer and a
one-sheet are not the same thing being
able to go to a movie and see a movie
with a fresh experience is what I think
we are all dying for I feel like you
could literally send out anything at
this point and fans would gobble it up
but we already have so much backstory we
already have such a set of anticipation
I just want people to be able to go in
and see it fresh and whether or not we
need a trailer or have to have a trailer
I think what we already have is a great
movie that we're gonna be able to watch
and let's have the movie be a goddamn
movie Cameron models the most powerful
entity going right now I think it'd be
real ballsy for them to just go alright
no and then I might drop I think Ben's
casual fans need to know this movie is
baby they won't make any money if they
just surprise drop it like a Beyonce
album there's several fun things that
Marvel could do that are either fake out
spoilers or just doing something tonal
or just taking out one sequence from the
film that people think are cool and it
will give some small modicum of joy to
this depressing
hell world we live in and if you don't
want to see it just don't watch it one
more thing one more thing anticipation
can be the greatest thing it's not it's
terrible what it's like nausea and you
know you're gonna vomit but in general
foreplay can
and be better than the real thing
[Applause]
[Laughter]
everything went into a hole
all right dan you check the fax is
currently the highest global grosser of
the year however domestically Black
Panthers number one by infinity war at
number two
Spencer brought up the fact that the two
things that you would see probably in
the trailer are the title of the film
and the release date it might be worth
noting currently that there's a rumor
reported online that the trailer may not
reveal the title and also that the
release date might change so there you
go
and where do we shake out on a trailer
is different than a commercial or the
same as a commercial a commercial is a
is made for television a trailer is
released in theaters but a trailer is a
type of advertising I think you're
getting the semantics thing right there
both advertising gotcha I would say well
right out of the gate Sasha and Cameron
just started hammering Spencer and
and I yeah and I felt Spencer was
getting a little bit overwhelmed but
then he just pulled out the practicality
card he asked me when it was coming out
and I'm like oh well I don't know the
exact date and then plus like I like
immerse myself in this stuff for the
regular you know Tom Dick and Mary like
that they need to find out when the hell
this movie's coming out they need the
information that is in that trailer they
need to go to the movies and see oh
that's coming out next weekend okay just
for the sheer practicality of it Spencer
ended up winning me over am I gonna get
you out I'm gonna go Spenny G on this a
second a second a third was counting a
second because there's midnight showings
okay so that's why it gave it me second
maybe people may see it on May 2nd
that's the actual releases the actual is
currently May 3rd let's do the Robert
we're down a junior tweets the release
take change together happen yeah so nice
do it twice so I am on the record very
stringently believing that Avengers 4
should not have a trailer yes do not
believe it should have a trailer but mmm
Spencer won me over
mmm I agree with you how the
practicality argument was very big in
his favor and I would also say that
Sasha and Spence a Cameron may be
focused a little too much on the
internet industry angle as far as
reaction videos please watch ours
whenever
we don't do live watch along sorry we
just know I have to go with Spencer all
right Rocky story yes line right two
points no foreplay
okay talk to us about the pole and this
pole is impossible because what 75
percent we have yes and with 24 percent
we have no and I guess 1 percent was
eaten by YouTube tweet that I had this
is really a yes or no answer so uh
people were tweeting their funniest
answers and that Benjy builder Minh said
when is the movie coming out by Spencer
Jake Gilbert is the movie fights live
version of sell me this pen from wolf oh
boy
absolutely great callback - yeah totally
makes sense Benjy builder man a pillar
of validation by the way all right
Spencer is up - Spencer says yes so now
you're like you know you're jinxing this
so hard
Spencer you have an opportunity to blow
a lead like nobody no-hitter you don't
say it but dislike the undefeated season
will you go undefeated like the Miami
Dolphins of the 1970s or lose the final
game like the New England Patriots from
several years back here we go
question number two sports okay the new
season of Mystery Science Theater 3000
Oh hosted by my pal geo Narae features a
surprise pick Mac and me that glass
sixth Ari about the alien and McDonald's
pseudo McDonald's what movie most
deserves the Mystery Science Theater
3000 treatment what movie most deserves
the MS
t 3k treatment and it's question two we
start with player two Cameron all right
I am going with no-holds-barred
the first ever WWE film starring human
garbage fire ho co-written by I think
someone else's credit as the writer but
I believe the story goes that a bits of
manacled Cogan over a weekend in a hotel
rewrote the entire script and it was in
the vault with two rich men in a hotel
room writing a script in the weekend
this movie is I think it's perfect for
the mst3k treatment much like Mac and me
it's a known bad movie but it's not so
known it's also a like Maccabees a
ripoff of ET no-holds-barred is a bad
ripoff of I think a rocky movie which
Rocky movie they're choosing to rip off
there's also a classic scene where Hulk
Hogan's intimidates a man so bad the man
puts his pants I would love to see what
mst3k could do with that whole story in
tune including the bar scene tiny Zeus
Lister it just goes on and on about how
insane this film is and the entire plot
of the movie is a television network
head wanting Hulk Hogan's wrestling
character to appear on his network so he
wants to destroy this other network and
makes no sense is one of the most 80s
things ever and I think mst3k could have
a field day with this
but like wrestling's also real but but
[Music]
yeah uh Gilbert look Hal I'm in the
making fun of movies game so when I
started what makes for the best movie to
make fun of I know what I'm talking
about and it needs to qualities for me
that make it easy and enjoyable one is
that the movie has to be ridiculous but
the movie also has to take itself
seriously hmm the movie has to think
that what it's doing is the most awesome
thing ever put to film that is why I've
chosen simply read the movie is called
rad if you're not familiar with from
1986 and this is I guess peak BMX I
don't know I haven't followed BFX before
or since
but man
this is just the most self-serious
thinks it's the most awesome thing of
all time it is your classic 80s got to
save the Rec Center win the thousand one
hundred thousand dollar BMX race called
hell track at the end it is about a man
who has to decide between Racing BMX or
taking the SATs that is major drama of
the movie he chooses the bike as you do
his girlfriend is is Rebecca from full
house and he takes her to prom whereupon
they both do their prom slow dance on
BMX bikes this is a movie that thinks
it's the coolest thing ever and it is so
ridiculous and that I think will make
for the best roast BMX or SATs there you
go Sacha well so I think it's so
interesting that you guys have both
chosen movies that don't involve science
[Laughter]
that is fun that is beloved but it's
also sort of sci-fi ish and that is the
brilliant the wonderful the charming
Starship Troopers here's what I'm seeing
I'm seeing a Mystery Science Theater
3000 show where Kasparov and Ian's
friend of screen junkies comes in and
helps along with it we have all the
campy fun we want but because this is
not an unknown quantity but a rather
known quantity we can also have this be
almost like a live the room but in your
own home so every time they say bugs we
could throw bugs at the TV every time
Rico goes Rico or takes a shower anytime
there's an awkward shower scene you have
to like throw water your do one it's
just a fabulous look a little spray
bottle and spritz it it could be a play
along plus it can be the great thing
that we love about mst3k but you also
have knowing that you talk about
self-serious you got the guy brought you
Robocop Total Recall and now you get to
revisit Starship Troopers which is so
delightfully bad but still so so good
and you have smart funny awesome people
yelling things you wish you would come
up with at your TV while you yell not
quite as good things at your
that's what I want I will not sanction
this Starship Troopers and not have you
call this a dumb movie this is one of
the most brilliant satire it says that
time of the century this is a genius
movie the dumbness of the characters is
the point that these are dumb jocks sent
off to war to die for a cause that they
don't even know about this is a biting
critical anti-fascist movie and I'm sick
as made by a man who grew up around
fashion made by man who'd escaped Nazi
Germany yes Paul Verhoeven is a genius
this is why I like yeah like you can
squint real hard and see subtext to
showgirls you can definitely see it to
Robocop and this movie too I think
deserves a revaluation not making fun of
it the movie is funny if you look at it
it's intentional what they're doing in
that film and then yours I think is I
don't know the movie speaks for itself
it's fun it's just a fun ride along and
they're cracking jokes do you think they
like you want someone to talk over when
that guy says Dookie no you want to sit
back and watch no holds barred it's
entertaining enough on its own red is
just a cheesy trope filled cheese fest
and you want smart people to interject
with like little commentary and little
snide comments throughout it'd be a
movie that's being expanded Nicole
Kidman but here's my thing you're
talking about how it's actually a great
satire my favorite episode in Mystery
Science Theater 3000 is when they did
Hamlet so you can do something that is
actually serious and make it really
really funny and really really
interesting because nobody would have
thought I was like Hamlet this is gonna
be garbage and I was howling so yes you
can still have something that is serious
is a satire is a great movie is a great
piece of art but it's an even better
episode of the show that's a hard one
come back from well I don't think you're
gonna come out looking as good you can
always make fun of Shakespeare cuz like
he's long dead this is a movie this is a
buddy whose legacy is still in
contention people still think Starship
Troopers is a dumb movie and I would
just be I would think less of mst3k if
they were making fun of how dumb
Starship I don't know they would because
Elliott Kaelin is the head writer of the
last two seasons of mst3k his show the
flop house they recommended it and their
point of view was critics got it wrong
they absolutely would because they did
RiffTrax back in 2013 I believed and you
can fact check that right well it's
you alone it's a lot of frustration okay
there's a live thing and what I'm saying
is they know that the comedies there
they know the jokes are there they know
that it would be awesome they've just
never done it for the actual show and I
want to be privy to what probably was an
awesome live event and the thing about
the MX's BMX is fun but it's not like a
great you need somebody where you can
make smart jokes about something stupid
but that just seems like stupid for
stupid sake that's what you want the
whole point of a see if their case to
make these stupid movies bearable and
fun and like you're all cracking jokes
about rags it's pretty rad it's written
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous but it's a very enjoyable
watch long when you're with funny people
talking about it that's what you want
this is a movie with the highest the
absolute highest discrepancy between
critics and user ratings
there is no other film that has a larger
gap between people's love for this movie
and what what are the rating and what I
think it's zero to 90 legs it's 0%
Rotten Tomatoes movie night and it's way
up there so people there's just
something really ridiculous about
watching this film and revisiting it
it's stuck in my heart it's stuck in my
soul and I would just love every time I
throw it on people like oh my god this
is so fun and we you make fun of it how
can you not make fun of a BMX slow dance
just about my movie wouldn't work
because it's fun it stands on its own so
you're now telling me your movies fun it
stands on its own
Cameron go ahead and turn this into your
final thought I think at the end of the
day mst3k works best I believe you made
this point when they're making fun of
movies that try to go for a mark and
miss that mark terribly Starship
Troopers hits the mark that it's going
for people might not have gotten it at
the time but it hits the mark it is
going for no-holds-barred is a perfect
microcosm of bad 80s missing the mark
trying to make Wall Street mixed with
rocky filled with people who cannot act
made by people who should not be making
movies if that does not say mst3k to you
and also let's take keep taking Hulk
Hogan down a couple notches less he's
brilliant comedian writers rip this man
apart further than he needs to be just
keep going at him
I think no-holds-barred as a movie to be
Thank You Cameron Spencer I just think
it's a perfect fit because of the trope
nosov it because this was such a
flash-in-the-pan
trend that that people thought was just
going to be the coolest thing of all
time
because it has
a race called hell track and because the
man and his love dance
they entwined their bodies and their
bikes at the same time I just wanted
it's providing you with the most
material and I do think that
no-holds-barred is too goofy and I do
think that Starship Troopers is in
itself a brilliant satire and you don't
want to talk over that this is a movie
with you've seen this movie before just
replace BMX with a dance-off with
skateboarding with anything you want
people to crack jokes over that Sancho I
feel like the reason that we've
rediscovered Starship Troopers is
because people got drunk and stoned and
watched it and made jokes over and then
people are like wait a second this movie
is awesome and hilarious but that's sort
of our generation it needs to be
rediscovered and it needs to be
discovered a first time but maybe older
viewers the truth is is that you're
talking about movies that have missed
the mark missed the mark is super super
on point they missed the mark they
totally got it wrong
we found it much later but Starship
Troopers is kind of a mess but it's done
so right when you get to watch it with
people that are smarter and funnier than
you and that's why it would be the
perfect thing and how dare you not want
to invite Casper Van Damme to the party
how dare you oh come time Randy as
always
he's a very nice gentleman and he smells
great absolutely I cannot vouch for how
he smells maybe Dan can dan facts about
everything including Casper Van Dien
smell yes
Casper Van Dien delightful man ripped
the door handle of an SUV once by
accident really kind of amazing open the
door just the handle came right off I
can't explain it to the stake yeah just
a few things the credited writer I'm not
making this up for a bill holds barred
is Dennis hacking it is reported that
Vince McMahon and Hulk Hogan checked
into a hotel in Reddington Beach Florida
and stayed up for 72 hours to rewrite
the script before the Sony bill Corbett
Kevin Reese Murphy and Mike Nelson they
do a thing called RiffTrax
they did do one for starship troopers
that you can buy now I'm a big fan of
attraction check them out Spencer you
are right a rat has a zero percent
rating only based on five reviews it
doesn't a ninety one percent based on
set over 7,000 user ratings but I have
to take you to task for your Paul
Verhoeven knowledge he is Dutch he did
not escape Nazi Germany but he did live
in the Hague next to a German base and
he saw a lot of bombings so okay did not
quite flee Nazi Germany but he was
witness to I was Internet correct you
were close correct but also completely
wrong correct yes that you gave who's
the UH newscaster the Brian Williams I
was in the chocolate
dan please give us your thoughts on them
on this round yeah I I feel like Sasha
got knocked out for me just because I
thought they made good points about the
nature of the film and the fact that
that's not it's not really a mystery
science that's more like a Rocky Horror
type thing I just don't think it really
fit the question that well so it's
between Spencer and Cameron for me and I
I feel like there was more a camera made
a better pitch for me for what what the
what the commentary would be and had
more aspects as opposed to Spencer's
which I agree said a ridiculous but also
awesome I feel like Cameron's pitched
for a movie to just do a total riff on
sounded better so I'm gonna go with with
Cameron all right that's one for Cameron
Sasha do you propose people throw actual
like real insects at their television
find those clicking cockroach you do you
boo boo that's that's tempting that's
tempting but yeah I got a yeah I feel
like they knocked you out for the same
reason and mention I felt like for me
Spencer was really just taking the lead
and he was had it by a nose all the way
but then when Cameron in his closing
arguments just reminded us oh we can
take Hulk Hogan down a peg even more and
just half the thing just hammering Hulk
Hogan that's like you don't even need
no-holds-barred to do that when you have
this quote-unquote dramatic movie to do
it and I saw I saw a no-holds-barred I
was little there's a huge WWF fan you
said W in the beginning by the way it
was WWF it says still now it says devta
be still right put it back in the day
WWF yeah but yeah I go Cameron as well
Cameron you take the point Spencer I'm
relieved to none of this week
what are they saying out there um well
go into the polls we had a tie at 19%
for Starship Troopers and no holds
barred and they actually went with red
with 61% um enough people knew about rad
I'm glad you know I think they wanted to
sweep you the voter rigged it on Twitter
Jesus 12 said wild wild west knows how
ridiculous it is while also being dead
serious
Will Smith is phoning it in at times but
you can also tell at one point he just
shrugged his shoulders and bought into
it and start act also featured a giant
steampunk spider
so that was their nomination for a great
rift mst3k movie where we go wah wah Wes
Wes Jim West alright so it is two to one
a Spencer over Cameron Sasha if you take
this point then you will face Cameron
into a playoff tiebreaker round mm-hmm
here is the question number three Mary
Poppins returns to Mary Poppins returns
is garnering critical acclaim few weeks
before even hitting theaters now we
asked what other Disney live-action
movie deserves a new sequel what Disney
live-action movie deserves a new sequel
we start with Matt on the end player
number three Spencer I'm a little
unclear cuz Mary Poppins returns it is a
sequel I guess right it's it's not like
a reboot cool no it's a sequel I think
we should make a sequel to blank check
hell I love that movie yeah I think that
there's nothing more fun as a kid and
the wish fulfillment in this capitalist
world it's brutal world ruled by dollars
and cents no bigger fantasy than just
getting a big wad of money written to
you after some guy ruined your bike so
if it's a sequel he grew up he had kids
of its own his kids on a bird scooter
and a park
and gets hit by some some Saudi Guyana
in a Hummer and he hands him a crypto
coin or something like that so this is a
this is a film about the booms and busts
the 1% versus the rest of us the the
wild fluctuations of modern-day
capitalism as told as only Disney from
today's headlines back around to Sasha
so I'm going with the movie that I
actually would love to see seek love
that we were supposed to see a sequel of
and that's the Rocketeer The Rocketeer
we were not ready in 1991 we are ready
now I want this to be I want to continue
the story so badly and with it we can
totally bring back down africana Lee who
only gets better with age and who
doesn't want another Joe Johnston movie
he was able to do so much with Captain
America the First Avenger and now I want
to see what he would do had he been
given the opportunity as he was supposed
to had it not bombed in 1991 to actually
continue the story and that I think
would be a fantastic movie all right run
Taryn Cameron I am going with the 80s
classic the flight of the navigator the
story of a young boy who falls down a
ravine and wakes up it's oh my god it's
eight years later and how did that
happen and he has an age turns out he
was taken aboard a ship and that ship is
voiced by Paul Reubens with some pee-wee
Herman and NASA is trying to get into
this boy's head because the boy's head
has all the information about all the
different goings-on in outer space and
so I think the sequel to this the ship
returns the boy now works at NASA and we
have a young female as the new navigator
glide and navigator to more navigating
which of the title
more navigating flight to more
navigating okay flava navigator doesn't
need a sequel it barely deserved a one
call it feels like et but like ETS
missing like this is just the this
really relies on the comedic value of a
ship that talks like Paul Rubens I know
I know and are you gonna be he's alive
you're gonna bring him back yeah he's
alive do people care I'm sorry how I
know you're a devout fan but like the
peewee voice in 2019 on a spaceship
moving under the Rocketeer there's he
did get his chance to make his
big-budget Rocketeer movie and that was
Captain America we have seen what he'll
do with that movie exists it would
really hit the same beats in the same
way of doing it is the sequel still a
period piece are we still going back to
that era in my my view is you go forward
27 years and you have Jennifer Connelly
who is now 27 years older and you do get
a young awesome female Rocketeer who
inherits the mantle who now can go off
and we can have this incredible radical
new adventure but it wouldn't be the
same kind of period piece 27 years
forward would be like sometime in like
the 19 late 1970s early 1980s so we're
more of like a cold war situation so now
it's us against Russia if you move
forward I think you lose the charm of
The Rocketeer which was that air and it
was such a good fit with like the art
deco and the 50s exceptionalism that is
going from the nineteen fifties you have
to go back to the 19th or whatever that
style is called I'm sorry I'm not an art
critic but then if you stay there then
it's then it is a retelling of Captain
America with a jet pack I think you're
screwed either way yours might think
about blank check is that a big part of
blank check it was there was all the fun
about him buying his own bounce house
and having a slide and this mansion
Elizabeth was great that was a lot of
great wasn't it great but there was the
degree of he was being chased after by
criminals and was the actor from Robocop
whose name I can recall Peter Weller I
know I wish no Magee's George please
cousin Kelly he's what he's the main
villain please yeah he's he's he's after
the kid and it becomes this kind of
crime thing and I think he even
threatens the kid with a gun in the
third act which is all fine I'm all well
and good but stakes are raised but so
the sequel is that it's this kids
children so how is it he does not become
part of the plot and be like hey don't
do exactly he's the the mentor that they
disregard he's like he's maybe penniless
and he's like don't go down the road I
did right I I spend my million dollars
on a castle which sure you know look at
the perils of not minding your finances
the way I did and then the kids like
screw you dad I'm going off vaping I'm a
jeweled scooter
Scooter beach yes okay so yes he's on a
sentient scooter made of jewels he's
dabbing on his haters he gets a crypto
coin the kid is an ass what kid gets a
million dollars it doesn't give like at
least some of it away or tell anyone
what an a-hole kid it just buys their
own home and like green-lighting our
trilogies and things that exist with IP
and if you actually wanted this movie to
get made it was meant to be a trilogy
you actually do it as a trilogy and The
Rocketeer was an amazing here okay is
there a 27 year time jump in the trilogy
no it was 27 years ago the movie came
out so 27 years hey listen I'm mobile if
you want to vote it back in time you can
put it back in time we can make it
current a it could be like a Top Gun
situation where the Rocketeer is like in
like the air force I'm saying they're
the only original cast member coming
back well Jennifer Connelly is the
hottest original cast member if you
would like to bring back others
I'm just saying Jennifer Connelly's in
you can actually build a film around and
you could build a franchise around and
you could bring like a young awesome new
talent in and it could be something if
you want to bring it into the under
other universes other parts of like the
Disney files you can make it part of a
Marvel thing we've had like Tomorrowland
I just don't think that throwbacks to
that era are as meaningful or as
impactful anymore because you're you're
stepping on well-trod territory
this isn't movie that people what's the
last Cold War late 1970s movie you saw
that was an action-adventure starring a
woman and Jennifer Connelly that's a
very specific question I really don't I
think this is something that we would
love to see and the movie has been
refound by fans and now we realize sort
of like Starship Troopers how great it
was we didn't we weren't ready we
weren't ready and now can someone make
me a mash-up of no one's ready for osco
with nobody was ready for rocket you
sold me a great poster but I have not
heard what the movie is you who are the
villains the Russians what do they want
they want the Rockets here after 27
years and no one grabbed it no wait hold
on are you seriously you with the flight
of the navigator oh my thing is pushing
stuff for here's what you do Disney you
do flight of the navigator to Disney
laws to put out Disney nature
documentaries every year and they put it
out in IMAX you make this the first
Disney IMAX movie where we also have put
in facts about space today so it's a mix
gonna make me learn oh
[Applause]
scares final thoughts Spencer Gilbert I
just think that the the premise and
setup is something that should be
revisited now more than ever of blank
check of sudden incalculable wealth and
the way people squander it and do a
responsible things that is something
that can be revisited and can be done in
an interesting way because I think it is
wish fulfillment but it's also be
careful what you wish for I think you
correct some of the mistakes of the
first one I think you could aside from
the hyperbolic kid things I was naming
you could do a better job than that of
updating it updating the specifics I'm
not the guy to tell you what teens like
these days but I do think I do think
that the film didn't it didn't do the
original didn't do the premise justice
and I think you could revisit it with a
different kid and a different setup and
and make a great movie and no one wants
to see another flight of the navigator
thanks penny gee I think that we all
wanted The Rocketeer to be better than
it was this is the opportunity to
actually see what it could have been and
you can have the trilogy that Disney
originally established this is a film
that was developed from 1938 and finally
came out in the 90s but still it's
something that Disney wants and we will
always see another like Lion King live
action animation whatever thing I don't
want that I want to know what happens
next in that story I want to see a
big-screen version of it I want to see a
female Rocketeer I want to see Jennifer
Connelly in an awesome action movie I
think you have so many opportunities to
make it period make it present-day do a
period that we haven't seen a million
times over and actually establish a new
trilogy that is dope that's what I want
thank you Cameron the original flight
navigator opened up with dogs catching
frisbees to Alan Silvestri score we seen
on Netflix dogs people love dogs you
open up fly the navigator to an IMAX
with some dogs catching frisbees you got
a billion dollar movie on your head
right now
I played charades with my dad and he was
trying to get us to guess and he kept
saying fly off the Navy alligator when
everything is later than average for
maybe Oh sounds like Dan fast a couple
things I love that we had the ultimate
transposition of actual person and
persona his Cameron said Paul Reubens
himself pee-wee Herman Rocketeer were
set 27 years after the original film
that would've take place in 1965 the
original took place in Los Angeles in
1938 you know I believe my math is
correct
so 1965 would be the year in which it
would take place the character itself
was created in 1982 took nine years to
get that film made by Disney very good
thank you sir
I threw it back 50 years yeah so uh
Cameron when you took it into that like
that weird IMAX and nature film realm i
won thank you yeah that was like that
kind of the shift of gears all of a
sudden was yeah it broad side of me a
little bit so came down to Sasha and
Spencer and I felt like Sasha I don't
know I feel like we were just going for
a little too much goodwill with I mean I
love Jennifer Connelly but like he said
at one point like she can carry the
franchise Jennifer Connelly
and then I think a lot of it was like
going on there The Rocketeer does have a
lot of goodwill but I felt like we just
heard more from Spencer as like just
some of the specific nuts and bolts and
just like you know just seeing some
little d-bag dabbing on haters and then
get his comeuppance
if the haters dead back help what if
they don't back what if they dad back
I go Spencer yeah navigator intrigued me
and then we started getting into dogs
and worried and all kinds of weird stuff
and I kind of lost the track on it a
little bit so it's between Sasha
expensive for me
yeah it's Spencer I you know I think it
was a bit muddled as far as exactly what
was gonna go on but I did like some of
the angles and I loved Sasha's idea I
really do with with Rockets here I love
up you know the fact that it was a
planned trilogy you could update that
but I felt like it was it was a lie I
never got a sense of like it could be in
the throw Beckman maybe we'll do it
modern and Jennifer Campbell McConnell
is in it but should be whatever you
wanted to be Dan just give me the money
with the purse strings which is my vote
I'm gonna give my money to the person
who seems to have a better idea of what
their movies gonna be its stead of just
writing a blank check Spencer you got
the point
when your haters what's up all right
well at 50% the chat was going real hard
for the Rockets here 36% for blank check
12% for flight of the navigator one a
penny time you do art you're gonna get
right in my heart at Grant K 1004 on
Twitter says after his dog his family
was dognapped buddy comes out of his
retirement to show he is great at one
last sport hunting Oh Air Bud taken for
a walk why the photo shop of Air Bud
with like a just go look at someone
brought us some facts oh I appreciate my
movie science says The Rocketeer
airfield that set pieces are still in
Santa Maria California and you can visit
them anytime
field trip ghost it could have been a
movie there you personally but yeah so
we are entering speed round game point
okay Spencer oh my god
no problem Cameron again here's how it
works I will ask the question shout out
your answer whoever answers first will
then get to elaborate first you get 20
seconds 20 seconds and then rebuttals of
ten seconds ten seconds again first
player to four points wins
Spencer is up three two one you all
ready for the speed round let's do that
let's do this okay and no time for polls
right now so Danielle will be chiming in
with her very own opinions and thoughts
thoughts yes what's the one Netflix just
paid an ungodly amount of money to keep
friends on the service what's the best
movie featuring any member of the
friends cast good girl
the good girl Ace Ventura pet detective
[Laughter]
Ace Ventura pet detective alright we
heard good girl first Cameron when 20
seconds begins when you speak good girl
is the directorial debut of writer Mike
White it's a film about Jennifer Aniston
plays a convenience the Commun store
Vaughn she works at like Avon's grocery
store it's a really kind of interesting
sad melancholy story that Mike Weitz
really good at about a young woman who's
trying to discover what she really wants
in life does she want to go stay with
her husband or does she want to stay
with Jake a young Jake Gyllenhaal who
goes by the name of hmm sounds like kind
of a slog Ace Ventura is the movie that
put Jim Carrey into the stratosphere it
is his finest comedic performance he is
completely unhinged it's like watching a
live-action Looney tune the the it's
actually not a bad like nor detective
story it just has a dolphin instead of a
murder suspect Courtney Cox is a great
supporting actress who plays against him
really well as the straight woman people
actually thought Jennifer Aniston should
have got nominated for an Oscar she
wasn't a lot of people are upset about
that and if you watch Ace Ventura pet
detective
it is pretty transphobic
I think movies from the 90's and before
have a lot of questionable things that
we could have to throw away half of all
comedies made before the year 1995 I
think that Jim Carrey's just alright
whoa there we have a good girl verse Ace
Ventura Danielle what you might be
reading the question for me so I can get
my my semantics on yes ma'am
Netflix just paid an ungodly amount of
money to keep friends on the service
what's the best movie featuring any
member of the friends cast um you know
these were both great arguments and
honestly normally I would I would agree
with Cam but can mostly gave me a film
synopsis whereas I felt like Spencer was
actually arguing which movie he felt was
better so before that I have to go
Spencer gotcha dan yeah not not to I
feel like it was just sheer volume with
Spencer came out swinging he listed
several reasons why a spent era was
notable and not not you not Cameron's
point that's a good knock back but how
people gave me so much
all plot synopsis and idea and not why
the movie was great I think just done
volumes Spencer had it and he took the
point for me and Spencer takes the days
[Applause]
too young for her for what I've seen
nicely done go ahead and give some
shouts give some thoughts tell folks
where they can find you
Oh shots to hell Rudnick Sascha pro
raver Cameron great great fight just
keep watching movie fights this is a fun
show I have nothing to shout out aside
from the thing I'm currently on yeah
thanks brother well played nicely done
thank you
you took that first question you're off
to the races
Cameron great having you I was and you
mentioned my quite via the Laura Dern
show that he didn't land yes enlighten
is a great show is only on for like two
seasons yeah um took taken way before
its time binge watch that crap on HBO
it's good stuff like really just gets
into like a troubled character and it's
funny dark comedy Cameron give us shout
outs tell us where we can find you oh
you can find me on Twitter on comm slash
dress Gailey and I write and host show
blood-curdling tales from the loop on
Tuesday nights at hyper RPG and also
follow my photo Instagram its cameras
photo on Instagram and watch
no-holds-barred
[Laughter]
Sasha pearl river critic movie mind and
mom me yeah tell us some stuff uh you
find me at Sasha Pearl River on Twitter
and Instagram and shoutouts to all of
these literally I walked in here it was
just like a hug central I love it in
your soul I'm so happy to be back and
you guys two things number one I
actually want the trailer and number two
I am a huge coming attract
[Music]
my mic to drop thank you for watching we
will be back live next year but yes we
have some great shows we haven't done
all of them we've done a couple of them
they're awesome
Oh back and watch us the resolution will
be better if only for that we're not
shooting him on a potato yeah and
they're not just generic it's like we
their upcoming events upcoming movies
that we're all looking forward to that
we're all mega pumped about so we are
tailoring them to those upcoming movies
so you're gonna want to tune in just as
per usual find me on all of my socials I
my patreon is still going I have started
modifying it so we were kind of doing a
Christmas movie theme we just did for
the live chats we just did the sequel to
a Christmas Prince I have not seen the
first one I will not see the first one
some of my favorite bad movies are also
online so he's chatting through those so
yeah not just a Russell content if you
would like to come into the chatroom
everyone in there is super super funny
and very kind and awesome and it's a
price of a cup of coffee a month coming
yeah I've worked thanks Danielle we
loves you check out her patreon and
thank you for checking us out super fun
hit me up on Twitter and Instagram at
Hal Rudnick and I want to wish a Happy
Hanukkah to any juicer in the house
q game and thanks again for watching uh
by L nation
[Music]
you